the fierce leader of sucker punches
women warriors was the lobotomized and
abused baby doll played by emily
browning
since that film browning has been busy
with a select group of interesting
thoughtful projects
let's take a closer look at what emily
browning has been up to since sucker
punch
since sucker punch emily browning has
largely opted for small
indie projects starting with 2011
sleeping beauty an australian made film
about a very specific kind of brothel at
which men pay to touch women who are
sleeping
it's easy to see the story as a
deconstruction of objectification of
women
and even a satire about valuing women
for their appearance rather than their
talents
the connection between the film and
sucker punch in which browning played
another woman misunderstood for her
appearance is clear
sleeping beauty was a huge challenge for
browning who not only had to be fully
nude on camera but also had to allow
intimate contact between herself and
other actors
browning said that her character lucy
was fascinating and a complete contrast
to her everyday self
telling indiewire i thought her
willingness and recklessness
and nihilism and her strength was really
cool
the fact that it made me uncomfortable
was a plus for me
it makes sense that browning who at the
time had gained attention from the mass
media and general public
might use this kind of film to question
her career and image
after sleeping beauty browning starred
in a couple of very different thrillers
magic magic and plush both released in
2013.
browning takes on more of a secondary
role in magic magic with her character
sarah who embarks on a road trip to
chile and gets caught in a game of
psychological horror
plush from director catherine hardwick
pushes browning quite literally into the
spotlight
she plays haley the ultra famous front
woman of a rock band named plush
who is stalked by a zealous fan the film
is part noir
part thriller and part horror and gives
browning a chance to flex some acting
chops as a brazen bold character in a
role that is a bit of a departure from
her previous films
browning's next major feature was summer
in february based on a true story and
set in the early 20th century
in it she plays florence carter wood a
woman caught in a love triangle with
artist alfred munnings and his friend
gilbert evans
the film is quite different from
browning's previous work even a bit
traditional
and is the first of a set of
love-oriented films that set browning on
a track to return to near blockbuster
films
the second title in this period is god
help the girl which harkens back to
browning's roots as a character in a
mental health facility
but combines it with her experience
playing a musician in plush
in this film browning plays eve a
secretly talented novice musician
who inadvertently brings two other
musicians together to form a band
browning is indicated in interviews that
she drew on her experience for eve
because eve is unable to feel settled or
comfortable unless she finds a way to
channel her creative energies
for her next project browning was in
2014's pompeii as the character kasia
the story is a fictionalized account of
the ancient city of pompei as it was
consumed by the eruption of mount
vesuvius in 79
a.d in interviews browning says that she
always wanted to play a character like
kasia
but the role never came up after pompey
browning starred alongside tom hardy in
legend
a crime thriller based on real life
events in which hardy plays the dual
role of twin brothers reggie and ron
cray
browning plays frances spouse of reggie
cray and describes her character as
attracted to reggie cray as a means to
escape poverty to the point where she is
willing to turn a blind eye to her
husband's criminal activities
remain in prison yeah prison you look
beautiful
after these two more prominent roles
browning turned back to small budget
indie films shangri-la suite and golden
exits
in shangri-la suite she plays one half
of a serial killing couple
bent on murdering elvis presley and in
golden exits
she provides an impressively textured
performance in a layered family drama
about relationships and desires set in
brooklyn
both of the characters in these films
are attracted to hopeless situations
that make them feel alive
and serve as the perfect segue for the
next chapter of browning's career
browning's most recent role landed her
in the acclaimed tv adaptation of neil
gaiman's american gods
in which she plays laura moon wife of
protagonist shadow moon
laura is a complex character one who
game incited as being difficult to crack
browning's performance has been widely
loved though even if her character is
describable as cheating
and selfish it's a testament to
browning's evolving skill as an actor
that she's able to elevate her role as
laura moon
to a level beyond that of the character
in the novel to the point at which her
own journey is on par with that of
shadow
the main character those four quarters
you just loaded
this is not 80s vegas they won't just
break your hands and let you walk away
they'll prosecute and push for maximum
sentence this recent role has brought
browning back into the limelight and
it'll be interesting to see where she
takes her career
from here regardless as a restless
relentlessly evolving actor
we can be sure that browning will not be
content to rest on our laurels
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one